[Applaudissements]
isabelle et bastia
on
[Musique]
si elle reste 5 millions si stockton
devant clem lundi d'accord je voudrais
juste m'adresser à celui qui a trouvé
les vêtements seal parce que les jeunes
sont habillés comme ça j'ai dit qu'ils
sortent un peu du a haussé de 5
représente au ont commencé moi vous
lisez prometeur première réplique
venez avec votre handball au gymnase
charles le manque jelly ailleurs on
aurait dit les visiteurs d978 tout à
l'heure mais bon j'ai trop le sun je me
fais je suis fait péta mon phone tel en
loucedé quand je peux pas tweeté je me
sens aussi iuf que ce boloss de gérard
louvin pas mort tu es aussi fraîche
qu'un glaçon j'avoue y a pas moyen qu'on
se presse la bouche quand je pécho la
bouche est obligée elle a encore un peu
de baume les messieurs vous regarderez
clem